not all Star Wars rumors are created
equal
many of the ideas are there for episode
9 while fun to consider are just too
outlandish to stand a chance of being
real other rumors though sound all too
plausible and that's not necessarily a
good thing one new report making the
rounds is raising serious concerns among
franchise fans getting people worried
that the saga concluding sequel might
just be a tired rehash of Return of the
Jedi
according to a report popularized by
youtuber Mike zero episode 9 will
include a gigantic planet-destroying
weapon yes again
the rumor hinges around a purportedly
leaked scene description from the
entitled Knight Star Wars Episode which
goes into detail about the attributes of
the supposed super weapon the scene
reports of these centers on kylo Ren now
the supreme leader of the villainous
first-order sitting in a room at what
seems to be the organisation's
headquarters he's said to be analyzing a
hologram displaying a yet to be
completed array of super weapons
according to the leak the son of Han and
Leia will be seen sizing up three
weapons shaped like cylinders with large
engines blasting blue and red energy
watching as they destroyed the terrain
of an unknown world while the weapon
appears capable of immense destructive
power it also seems to still be under
construction sound familiar
some have noted that the rumored weapon
sounds strikingly similar to a world
Devastator which is a form of Technology
featured in the old Star Wars Expanded
Universe particularly the Star Wars
legends dark empire story designed by
Imperial engineers who helped craft the
original Death Star the well devastators
are described as weapons at land on
planets and he used tractor beam
technology to rip the land apart
decimating everything in their reach
while the Death Star's were incredibly
effective mass killing machines the
world devastators take things one step
further by extracting the rubble from
destroyed planets the weapon ships armed
to the teeth with guns
lasers missiles ion cannons and more
would harvest the remnants of ravaged
worlds for fuel and resources which
would then be used to power the ships
engines the salvaged material would also
serve as fuel for the ship's internal
foundries which were used to create more
cruisers droids and destructive weapons
while the world devastates a Zant
currently a part of Disney's revived
Star Wars Canon there's nothing stopping
episode 9 director JJ Abrams from
digging through the series history books
and bringing
past elements back into the fold but
just because it's plausible doesn't mean
that fans want to see it happen on
screen if the new movie really does
feature yet another giant weapon based
on Deaf star tech it would feel
remarkably similar to Return of the Jedi
not to mention the original Star Wars
movie or the force awakens more the
seventh Star Wars Episode also directed
by Abrams was praised for how it reacted
that classic Star Wars feeling after
years worth of weird prequels many
rolled their eyes of the inclusion of
Starkiller base a bigger badder Death
Star in everything but name after the
divisive responds to the last Jedi which
tried to take the series and some
controversial new directions as well as
a muted reaction to the Han Solo
spin-off it's possible that Disney and
Lucasfilm will want to play things safe
for the series ninth episode maybe the
idea is to go back to what worked before
instead of risk alienating people again
with something new but as the firm
reaction to the rumor seems to indicate
there is such a thing as being too
familiar some people are even making
arguments in support of the prequel
movies which at the very least seem to
try new things even though they didn't
always stick the landing to many viewers
Star Wars should be about more than just
laser swords Death Star's and Darth
Vader going back to that well too many
times seems to speak to a lack of
imagination and even risks turning
people off the series for good but is
this rumor true we don't know but it
feels believable and that's why as fans
worried star wars are supposed to offer
a whole galaxy of ideas not just the
same one over and over it's hard to
imagine anyone being satisfied with
another super weapon serving up the
climax of the decade spanning Skywalker
saga
there's no way episode 9 will satisfy
everybody but karna at least tried to
surprise us we can only hope we'll find
out for sure what's coming down when the
movie hits theaters on December 20th
2019
[Music]